i've met brandy and i don't know i'm
sitting up in my room anybody can write
that jam i i would trust her with
anything
[Music]
all right y'all so there's a new show
called girls five ever coming out on
peacock about a 90s girl group
reuniting after many years out of the
limelight a lot of comedy to be had
there
the cast is stopping by our show so to
celebrate their appearance and all
things 90s i'm going to play a game of
who would you rather 90s music edition
let's do this
who would you rather take home to meet
your mom emcee hammer or some mix-a-lot
well we got a lot of booty in my family
so i'll be taking sir mix-a-lot
because i know he'd be into my family
not one of us doesn't have a giant
behind
who would you rather play beer pong with
at a party cher or madonna
oh man i think i have to pick cher on
this one
i don't know i think i ran into her once
and she just seemed like
really like nice and down to earth but
also just like
really fun and like really says whatever
she's thinking that's both i just
described both women these are hard
yeah i mean i guess i'd say share i
heard that cher once lived in burleson
texas which might be a lie but i heard
she did and i did too
at one point so we're so much alike
who would you rather be in a group text
with the spice girls or destiny's child
i mean i guess i'm gonna pick destiny
shocks that's what dude i knew all their
songs
like growing up i knew some destiny's
shot stuff i didn't know spice girls as
well
but i definitely did know bugaboo all
those songs
i was a big big fan or am a big big fan
not
was who would you trust to run your
social media for a day
anyone but me
[Laughter]
any takers so that be nsync or
hanson i don't know i think i don't know
hansen and i've met a few of the guys in
nsync and i think they're funny
so i would probably pick them but i
don't know hansen could be
a riot i don't know who would you rather
steal
clothes from tlc or no doubt oh that's
tough but here's why i'm going to go tlc
because they wore baggy clothes
and generally thick girls aren't into
like
other kinds of clothes like we enjoy a
bag i was real into those like baggy
sweatshirts and baggy pants i was like
yeah this is so cool and hip not that
i'm hiding anything
um and i i love both though i was a no
doubt and tlc fan
i will say though tlc no doubt isn't
even a girl group but i just mean
tlc is pr possibly my favorite girl
group ever
who would you rather write a song with
elena's more set or fiona apple
i mean probably atlantis morissette
because literally she's one of i love
both
female right they're both incredibly
cool and strong and powerful
um and talented but um i met alanis and
she did my show as well
um and i was very excited and i i just
think she's she's
a great example of a woman she's you
know very bold very talented
very um smart um and and
i don't know just like when i was a kid
i wanted i wanted to write a song as
cool
as elena's more set was writing um she
and patty griffin are probably two my
favorite writers on the planet
who would you rather crowdsurf with at a
show whole or garbage
oh both sound fun i like coal and
garbage so
i feel like i'm gonna go shirley manson
y'all i feel like i'm gonna i feel like
i'm i'm more of a shirley mancy girl i
don't know why i just feel like we would
vibe and also we have the same stylist
um candace who won stylist of the year
last year she's amazing
um and candace has also mentioned that
we would get along
who would you trust to keep your biggest
secret
brandy or monica well i've met brandy
and i don't know i'm sitting up in my
room anybody can write that jam
i i would trust her with anything and
cinderella remember when she and whitney
did cinderella
i was watching that with my daughter the
other day and my daughter's so funny
because she literally like no matter who
she sees singing she's like they're not
you mommy and i'm like
i hope this lasts forever
you know because it's like everybody
could come it doesn't matter who
composed your kid compliments you and
you're like i am a hero
in her eyes but anyway but then it
starts to get a little embarrassing
cause i'm like okay when you hear people
saying don't tell them
that because she'll literally just be
like no
and i'm like oh my god like you know you
got to be nice
um but it's real sweet who would you
rather share the super bowl halftime
show stage with
whitney houston or mariah carey uh
it'd be pretty miraculous to share it
with houston
so i guess i'd pick mariah carey because
um she's alive so um
i would if they were both alive that
would be a really hard thing for me
those two women like are seriously
like two of the reasons why i'm a singer
so
um i'm just such a huge fan of whitney
and mariah and then when they did the
prince of egypt song
what when you believe i believed i was
there
a modest singing a talent show and one i
love both women and i know both of their
catalogs like
not just know the songs like know all
the riffs
know old book where they take breaths
like like any
any like thing happening there i know
wouldn't that have been a great super
bowl
whitney and mariah why didn't they do
that like around like the when you
believe
time i don't know because everybody used
to pit them against each other too
and let's be real they're very different
yes they are both
soulful singers and you know uh great
likes uh just i don't know soulful pop
singers like
they've got that whole thing going for
it but but they're totally different
artists
and nobody gives mariah i think the
credit that she deserves
one though as a songwriter like mariah
wrote
almost every single if not most of them
are all of them like
if she's she's a an amazing songwriter
as well then there's the bodyguard
and i can watch that every month all
right y'all that was a lot of fun sorry
i
went on a lot of tangents you're welcome
um but
that was uh all in you know play just
because
we love girls five ever and the cast of
girls father that's coming on the show
and they're hysterical and awesome okay
bye
want more fun stuff i thought so check
out these videos floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure